2016 was the year that Islamist
terrorism hit Germany hard culminating
in an attack on Berlin Germans have been
shaken their convictions tested
Chancellor Angela Merkel acknowledges
the challenge facing the country
distress the poi fungus on earth life
without a doubt the most difficult test
we face is the mist terrorism which has
also had us Germans in its crosshairs
for many years the film's mid- this past
year we were attacked in the cities of
roots Berg and dance bar and just days
ago at the Christmas market at the
Memorial Church here in Berlin it's a
bitter reckoning and a despicable one
when terror attacks are committed by
people who came here ostensibly to seek
safe haven ungulate shoots all the
attacks are ammunition for those
demanding stricter security measures
even politicians from Merkel's own party
have demanded Germany stops taking in
refugees an idea Merkel rejects years
and fly we are a free caring and open
people oh and as we are confronted with
images of the bombed-out city of Aleppo
in Syria we reiterate how important and
vital it has been for our country to
take in those who truly needed
protection and to help them become
integrated here von Goethe not here
Bolin stood so fasten point the integral
politicians and parliamentary democracy
have been under pressure in 2016 Merkel
warns the populace give a distorted view
of democracy a concern in the upcoming
elections ETA limit for an applet
assault I am committed to engaging in a
political process that will see
impassioned debate among Democratic
citizens who never forget what an honor
it is to serve our democracy and its
peoples al wahda makati or dammit didn't
mention pseudonym an M diviere appeal
for an open-minded worldview and for
Germans to have confidence in themselves
and their country